this capsule we will introduce the
first round logic concept
and then we will see that the euro that the
logic of the first role can play in
artificial intelligence
so the purpose of this capsule and
the ones that will follow
it's going to be to understand what the
first-time logic so between
others know the syntax the logic
of first rank may have commented on this
we can describe facts in language
natural in a logical form of
first order and we also want to see
and know how to make
deductive reasoning in logic of
leading roles ie is in
able to demonstrate or prove
new made from a base
initial fact with what's called
the proof by resolution the one we see
the logic of the first role is actually
a language that will be useful for
describe knowledge in a
premium context in intelligence
artificially noted that research
heuristic that we were able to
solve several problems under the
form of a search in a serious of
tops and for a problem you have me account
complete that it's going to be often building
problematic to describe in one form
symbolic or and mathematics or even
in a computer
what do these ethologists
6.1 and at the expense of
knowledge of an expert also the
transitions between the states of the lyrics
will not always go obvious from a
side that in a computer what would
helpful actually it would be to have a
language to represent the set of
his knowledge that we want to exploit
in our intelligence system
artificial training or even a language
which would represent the
knowledge of this experience and who
allows me to easily make
logical deductions from his
knowledge to be able to
reason logically in this
knowledge area of ​​the expert
so for his vote used what we
calls the first two logic
which sometimes also called calculates the
predicate so that's the basis of
many is the basis of many
representation list formats of
intelligence knowledge
artificial and it will allow us to
make deductive reasoning that goes
among others allow us to
develop what we will call
expert systems ie
systems that captured the expertise
of an expert and which are systems that
are able to exploit this
block expertise to reproduce it and
make recommendations in a
given problem
originally we made the logic of
first order is really a model
mathematical deductive reasoning
not deductive reasoning we mean
a process that makes it possible to
the expression inference will read
true expression from facts
known to the world and then some
assumptions that we make with respect to this
world there and so the ability to
model a deductive reasoning go
allow us thereafter to
program this reasoning support so
to make a design of what I called
expert systems that's why
it's important to see the formalism
mathematical first order logic
to know then we must have described
the language comment on what we can
the printer and then simulate the kind of
expertise that can be modeled with
first order logic
but some examples of one can make the
deductive reasoning so
imagine that we are in the time of
Rome and then we have different sons on
a given situation
so we have to marcus and we do not
mark it is a marcus person is a
pean bridge
all firefighters are Caesar Romans
is a leader
everyone is loyal to someone all
the Romans are loyal to Caesar or the
the only leaders
no one tries this sinister have known
to which she is not loyal and
finally marcus tried to murder
Caesar so let's imagine we all have this
what is our knowledge base
let's imagine now that we want we want
prove that marcus to grab it from
of all these facts then this is a
review made that we will review the capsules
who
who will follow because it's a
relatively healthy example pretty much
maybe such a sign that it's not
truly representative has refueled
problems that will take shape
very similar that is to say we will
want to prove something from
of a knowledge base so a
problem that will seem maybe a
little bit more useful it's on a
patient who has several symptoms that
registered in our knowledge base
we know what the rules of
causality between symptoms and
pathologies and that we struggled
causality on treatments that we
could offer ben patients in this
case also an application problem when
even nothing to solve is to infer that the
the patient's disease and in addition is in
able to say what is the treatment
suitable for special so with the
first-order logic and among others
the proof by resolution is something
something we will be able to try to
solve is another problem that
basically the same thing
but in the automotive world
we could have a car for
which one wants to diagnose what is it
his problem
so that's why we need 5
tons we get a little trash to talk
of symptoms for a car but it's
in fact the equivalent of 70 for a
nobody so what are the problems
associated vehicles that we observe is
what are the rules of causality
for mechanics that could not go up
to be able to say what is it
the problem source the storm to solve
for another vehicle
so that's exactly the same type of
problem we have knowledge bases
then we would like to prove doing the
demonstration of something in this
case demonstrate what is the problem
associated with our vehicle then in this
this is what the disease this to
patients so I have not seen the system
expert before we will not see that in the
detail in these capsules 6 but so
general the system expert this system where
we have a knowledge base that
we were specified by an expert so
who has formulated us all of
facts on a given area that this
nobody knows at this 200 we will see
other potentially new facts that
are brought so it could be
a knowledge base to be
the knowledge set of a doctor
in relation to medicine then challenge it
could be observed symptoms
in a patient and expert systems
will then be able to make a
interrogation ie to ask a
some questions in relation to a
possible illness for our patient by
example and to first order logic
gold a search engine that will do
of reasoning then who is going to be in
able to give us an answer to the
any end
we can also use the logic of
first run in planning in this case
also we have an agent and imagine that
our agent can run multiple
tasks in a given environment like
a robot that can manipulate objects
in his environment and imagine
we want to give a goal to our age
we want them to do something
thing for example our good would like
that they move
some objects from one place to another
and I do not look at your list of
business operations by so the list
business operations to accomplish
the goal is not to code advanced so we
is really in a context
artificial intelligence
we want the agent phase ii by itself
even planning so the list of
offered actions to reach the goal
so we've already seen algorithms
how stars that allows us to do
that if we specify the goal before we
can build a graffiti at all this
environment where when we reach the
purpose we know that our research must
stop and then do a search
with canvas with logistics that
some properties well there we are sure
we will have found when the strike
in order to exist the necessary plan
the benefit of first-order logic
you know we will have known a lot more
easy to build this graph the child
so we will be able to formulate with the
logic of the first run all of
facts knowledge of actions
possible consequences of actions
of this agent their in their environment
and that that allows you to the same
system to actually solve several
possible tasks
so it's going to be easy for
to change the purpose and name it in fact a
very big not what we will see language
now to describe the goals so that's
is going to be a simplified way
then well formal to specify braids
very precisely what is the goal
when we want our agents to solve
wood hero encloses specified multiple
so in the world of the web was what we have
seen in another capture which one
could for a given situation say
inside we want them to find
their or in another we could say
you are the web can he have a language
are a language that allows me to
to formulate his two things there we go
can use the same system for
solve the same problem of plastic
planning ie determining the
list of actions to be found during
where to find the group is therefore alone
advantage of the utility of the logic of
first order in planning so in
logical the first rank which is going
distinguish two aspects that we want
cover in the capsules that are
so come in fact the veracity of a
expression to logic the veracity
logic of an expression goes depends on
two things it will depend on doing
defection true that we do not suppose
have a given situation so by
example that all people are
dead she a patient some
temperature or that a car starts
association of facts that can be described
that we will describe according to some
syntax between the syntax of logic
first rank so this is the first
something we will have to review how
Can we take those facts?
then describe them in a language the
logical language of first rank and so
that will allow us, among other things,
specific what is true to
to know exactly how weak it is
that all people are dead
she is true that passionate
temperature of 40 degrees thus killed and
another part another another another
aspect that will need to demonstrate
the veracity of a new expression of
make the new deduction
expressions their logical expression
that they're real it's going to actually depend
of syntactic manipulation from
facts that are green that will us
allow for new derivatives
expressions
so if we have the fact that being a
no one imply immortal and that
dupont is a person
Well, it turns out that we can deduce
so let it be there a person
let's apply is deadly and that in addition to the
bridge is a person who can
logically deduce that dupont is dead
she's actually doing this reasoning
there what we will see what we can do
syntactic manipulations one can
to convert the facts that we have plessis
in a slightly more mathematical form
so pay that implies m 2 x for
all x and peace has therefore explained even x
for all and that would be a way
to express one's personality
immortal can be a way of saying
that a person to a person is so
there is a person called to and to
from that way purely this
accident is able to tell true that
m
to is also true and it was done without
senna noticed that t as and pie x are
basically the same thing it's
just that one just needs to
take support of assigning it to x and
barley is a country x so to associate
ap one so that will mean that pea
imply my and so I could add
our knowledge base and so me
the game describes them in words so no
very strong even is what we will see
is that this title of deductions the man
we will be able to formalize it on the form
of a difference rule faced took the
resolution that goes is a rule when
even pretty flexible and general then who
will allow us to do several
types of logic manipulations purely
syntactically that is to say that we are
simply manipulate the symbols
associated with the truth they were
expressed in the knowledge base
for like that in derivatives again
again in the form of the
first order logic